دبابير هكذا تصف القوات الاسرائيليه مخيمه
جنين النقطه الاكثر اشتعالا التي شكلت
صداعا لصناع القرار الاسرائيليين مخيم
جنين الواقع شمالي الضفه الغربيه انشئ عام
1953 على مساحه تقارب نصف كيلو متر مربع
يعد ثاني اكبر مخيم في الضفه بعد مخيم
بلاطه ويسكنه نحو 27 الف فلسطيني ينحدر
اصل معظم سكان هذا المخيم من منطقه الكرمل
في حيفا و جبال الكرمل وقراها وقرى جنين
المحتله عام 48 اصبح المخيم خاضعا لسيطره
السلطه الفلسطينيه في منتصف التسعينات الا
انه كان عرضه لحوادث عنف كثيره خلال
الانتفاضه الثاني عام 2000 القوات
الاسرائيليه دخلت المخيم والمدينه في
ابريل 2002 واعلنتهما منطقه عسكريه مغلقه
فارده حظرا مستمرا على التجول هناك عمليه
حينها عرفت بمجزره جنين واسفرت عن تدمير
ما يقارب 150 مبنا وتخريب المئات وغيرها
ما ترك اكثر من 400 عائله من سكان المخيم
دون ماوى دخول مخيم جنين اليوم اشبه
بالولوج الى فكره عسكريه تحصينات بدائيه
اعتاد متواضع سلاح خفيف حيث تنتشر على
مداخل المخيم عوائق معدنيه بدائيه الصنع
مصدات شوكيه لاعاقه المركبات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه تحيط بهذه العوارض اسلاك هذه
الاسلاك موصوله بعبوات ناسفه محليه الصنع
تشغل على جانبي تشغل على الجانبي الطريق
المؤدي الى حارات المخيم المتاريس الرمليه
ايضا منتصبه على مداخل الاصدقاء وحتى
الشوارع الضيقه لهذا المخيم في مطائرات
الاستطلاع الاسرائيليه المعروفه محليا
باسم الزنانه زائر دائم في سماء المخيم
لمطارده اي تحركات رغم ان مخيمه جنين لا
يختلف في الجوهر عن اي مكان فلسطيني اخر
تستهدف اسرائيل الا ان صموده يتمثل بدخول
جيل جديد من المسلحين الى المعادله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات